for the second time a jury has found
Monsanto's Roundup weedkiller played a
role in causing cancer
yesterday's unanimous decision
determined roundup caused or was a
substantial factor in causing
seventy-year-old
Edwin hardiman's non-hodgkins lymphoma
Anna Warner is here with how this
verdict could affect thousands of other
lawsuits claiming the herbicide causes
cancer yeah good morning good morning
this is just the first phase in
hardiman's case against Monsanto and its
new parent company Bayer which contains
roundups active ingredient glyphosate is
safe attorneys will now go back to the
jury to decide whether or not the
company is liable and has to pay
monetary damages Edwin hardiman's
attorneys say he started using roundup
products back in the 1980s to treat
poison oak and weeds on his property in
Northern California he continued to do
so until 2012 three years later he was
diagnosed with cancer roundup extended
control roundups manufacturer says its
product is not to blame
in a statement Monsanto's parent company
Bayer says we have great sympathy for
mr. Hardiman and his family but an
extensive body of science supports the
conclusion that roundup was not the
cause of his cancer the jury disagreed
unanimously deciding that roundup was
responsible this is the second time a
jury has ruled against the products
manufacturer in August of last year
duane lee johnson was awarded 289
million dollars in damages after the
Court determined roundup was also a
substantial factor in causing his
non-hodgkins lymphoma a judge later
lowered that award to 78 million dollars
and Monsanto has appealed
I spoke with Johnson last year what did
that verdict mean to you the verdict
really meant to me that this thing was
not done in vain and I remember standing
there saying to myself if I lose this
case this company is going to be able to
get away and then they'll be able to say
see I told you our stuff didn't do that
attorneys for Edwin Hartman say their
client is pleased with the verdict in a
phone interview co-counsel jennifer
moore says in the trials second phase
they'll seek to prove Monson
knowingly mislead the public they knew
for decades that roundup can cause
cancer and frankly they just didn't care
this is a big loss for Bayer and
Monsanto it proves that juries are being
convinced that roundup is causing cancer
and there's a lot at stake here Bayer is
facing more than 11,000 lawsuits
connected to roundup now it contends the
jury's decision Tuesday has no impact on
future cases and trials they say each
one is different legally and factually
and says more than 800 studies from
around the world confirm the product is
safe when used as directed but there's
not total agreement on that state of
California disagrees another world
agency at arm of the w-h-o disagrees it
seems like the jury didn't come to this
decision lightly either Anna thank you